ん
[音楽]
などねー
本当に差分いっすよ味でガチで俺怒ってるからポンっとにさあマッチで捌い
6すぐ寒すぎて本当に寒来てね俺は今日ねぇ
学校サボろうと思ったよ
サボったけどひょっと良い趣味等カレーライスが好きです彼らにする僕は姉
まあ言っちゃうか狙いするみたいなもんなんで僕はも枯れないし大好きです
も多分君たちの想像ハルクに上回るカレーの好き者でしてなカレー屋さん
有名なお店があるじゃないですかーデーこの汗ですよ
そうちょっと違うまたたそうここ一番カレー coco壱番屋っていうさん保有さあ
ここ1ってカレー屋さん
ココイチ
でそのかやさんにですね甘さを選べるつを待って俺らの言葉がおかしい
そうでレートのココイチってカレー屋さんのですごいところは彼は自分でトッピングと
加工
カスタマイズできるんですよ例えばた大カレーが飛びたい人は感想を調節したり
たくさん食べたいって人は量を調節したり宮トッピングも猫自由にカスタマイズとが
できてねもうほんとにねー
グレートなカレーアウター察するような1つだけ弱点が出てそう
俺に
ですアバックずしか食べれない輩にはもうちょっと弱点がありまして甘口学校調節でき
ない
辛口とかいろんな種類があるんですけどもなく車
合う靴しかないっていうね
[音楽]
なんでもないですなんだけどもなんか最近ココイチでなんとですね甘さを選ぶことが
できるようになったそうです
市山井山さんは山が張ってこう
どんどん強くなってるですアバさが後雨だってね一番の20倍なんですよ
100円多いですよ
竜の子アーマー機を買ってきましたこれが今後雨ですこれが
coco壱番屋ってカレー屋さんで最もかないのが今ここにあっちが名前なんか
国家カレー coco壱番屋で一番可愛い
あーから一番やで一番うまいのはいえばここにありますちょっと実験的にやってる
らしいです一部の店舗でそういう甘さを選べるっていうシステムがこう表現されてて
たまたまそれが来てたんです
何とか買えたんでね食べてみようよ
余地が俺が食べます全国に30て北大しかもよろしいですうん
ういち yammer の20倍の山で
俺ちょっとこれはあんまり言っちゃダメなんですけどボケちゃんはニャーとさあまくっ
たんですよ
ディアはとさあも凄い美味しかったですもうまさに俺の求めるね理想があなただったん
だけども
店員さんにその後孔を食べる勇気がなくてそのテーマに聞いたんですよ
5あってどーすかって言ったらまずいでって言われました
アプリ言っちゃダメですよこれ本当にダメなので首になっちゃうかもしれないんで
さっそく食べてみようと思います
ごまです
まず大丈夫だいただきます
[音楽]
ええええええブーブーそうアーはやばいなんかねあの方にいうとあれです蜂蜜ライス
みたいなんかご飯に蜂蜜をかけて食べてる感じで諏訪魔はやめてね
ニアはサーモぐらいがオススメだと思います
ぜひ食べてみてくださいじゃ